[Music]
another thing that I'm going to be
stressing a lot and playing with a lot
is the fact that your environment will
often give you great opportunities for
playing with many of these concepts
sometimes you know vaguely precarious
opportunities but opportunities
nonetheless so this narrowed loboc gives
me a great opportunity to play with the
idea of tracks I've got a clear
application of one track and a clear
representation of the other track if I'm
facing you I'm crossing back and forth
and track the track it's a forwards
cross and I'm spotting the very end of
the dock and kind of trying to make my
x-ray than that if I'm over on this side
I've got a clockwise circle on this side
I've got a counterclockwise circle and
I'm facing away I'm doing a backwards
crossing at the far end of the dock so
let me just have to play along the dock
and I'm on one plane I'm on the other
plant I'm on this plane I'm on this
plane and I switch back and forth
between same tracks and planes you'll
just have to bear with me and not only
am i playing with my tracks in my
crossing but I'm also being forced to
really feel what's going on with my
stepping and my environment and whether
I'm stepping forwards and backwards
because if I knew anything wrong I'm
gonna fall into a very cold lake on this
side on this track I can paint along the
side along this wall plane on this side
I can paint along this one like I've got
a big paintbrush I'm painting these
circles I'm facing you like a complier
lower wide narrow here if backwards
narrow and wide and high and low and
pretty quickly what happens I really
start feeling this my body gives me a
real visceral feedback so it doesn't
have to be a doc it can be the lines on
the tennis court the path it can be a
bridge it can be the sidewalk
anything that gives you this clear
geometry and all of this again it's like
training wheels it's really great to
start with these clear
you know geometries and later you start
to let go of that and move in arcs and
circles and you know octagons whatever
you want but in the beginning it can
really make the first concepts easier if
you think along the terms of these
tracks so find something your
environment and have fun
[Music]